حسنًا ، علمنا هذا الأسبوع أن بعض
حلفاء الناتو يرسلون أولى
الطائرات المقاتلة إلى أوكرانيا ، كيف يغير ذلك
حساب التفاضل والتكامل للحرب ،
لذا فإن هذا مثير جدًا للاهتمام الآن
لديك كل من بولندا وسلوفاكيا تقدمان
طائرات للأوكرانيين ، هذه كلها طائرات من طراز
ميغ -29  التي كانت في جرد
كلا البلدين أه منذ أيامهم في
حلف وارسو ، لقد بدأت هذا يؤتي
ثماره بمجرد إرسالهم
للطائرات أه التي يمكن أن تحدث
اختلافًا تكتيكيًا على الأقل ولكن هناك شيء واحد
يجب مراعاته حول هذا  هو أن
أنظمة الدفاع الجوي لكل من روسيا
وأوكرانيا كانت فعالة جدًا في
إخراج الطائرات من السماء ،
نظرت إلى بعض الإحصائيات
ويعتقد أن حوالي 70 طائرة روسية قد تم
إسقاطها خلال
الحرب وحوالي 60 طائرة  لقيت الطائرات الأوكرانية
مصيرًا مشابهًا ، لذا عندما تضع كل
ذلك معًا ، يكون مكانًا خطيرًا
للطائرات من أي نوع كان في
السماء ، لذا لن يكون هذا الدواء الشافي
للأوكرانيين أه أو لأولئك الذين
يأملون أن يتمكن الأوكرانيون
يسودون في السماء يمكنهم
القيام بالكثير من الأشياء الجيدة ولكن عليهم توخي
الحذر الشديد بشأن الطريقة التي
يفعلون بها الأشياء
الأجنبية